[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
inicio el mes sagrado del ramadán y al
menos la mitad de la población del
continente africano vive con intensidad
estos días de ayuno y oración algunas
más mezquitas reabrieron sus puertas a
pesar de las medidas para evitar
contagios por ccoo bit 19
[Música]
tenemos para ustedes la historia de un
rey afrodescendiente y su esposa que
mantienen viva la herencia africana en
bolivia en medio de modestas condiciones
el rey julio pinedo defiende su linaje
en medio de las dificultades
y marruecos es el país del continente
africano que más ciudadanos ha vacunado
a la fecha con más del 12 por ciento de
la población inoculada con la primera
dosis contra el coi 19 hablamos con un
experto epidemiólogo marroquí para
conocer detalles de la campaña masiva
[Música]
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días los musulmanes del
mundo viven los primeros días del
ramadán
la conmemoración más importante para el
islam que consiste principalmente en un
mes de ayuno y oración este mes sagrado
del ramadán está marcado por las medidas
de prevención contra el coni 19 en el
continente africano se cuenta un alto
número de musulmanes en países como
senegal donde cientos de fieles se
reunieron en la mezquita de más al iq
giral una de las más grandes de áfrica
occidental
un nuevo ramadán más parecido a lo que
siempre había sido se vive en el
continente africano a pesar de la
pandemia de kobe 19 miles de fieles
musulmanes celebraron los primeros días
del mes sagrado del ramadán muchas veces
sin tener en cuenta las medidas de
bioseguridad en dakar la capital de
senegal los creyentes celebraron la
reapertura de las principales mezquitas
de la ciudad
se otorga twr elena fiel a las
oraciones super rogativas el año pasado
ramadán 2020 no pudimos hacer eso él se
la bancó podemos decir que este es el
primer año desde la apertura de la
mezquita que comenzamos a hacer estas
oraciones nocturnas del mes de ramadán
de pierre nocturno
con la situación actual del mundo estaba
realmente ansioso por realizar estos
actos de devoción cientos de fieles
musulmanes se reunieron durante la
primera noche del ramadán en la mezquita
más al likud gin and in dakar una de las
más grandes de áfrica occidental
inaugurada en 2019 y que permaneció
cerrada durante 2020 debido a la
pandemia de coronavirus para seguir más
que feliz estoy realmente conmovida y ni
siquiera puedo decir lo que realmente
siento y asiste a durante tantos años
hemos estado orando para asistir a este
evento que inaugura las oraciones del
mes de ramadán aquí en milán con la
condición de respetar las medidas para
evitar
por coronavirus las oraciones colectivas
del mes sagrado del ramadán están
permitidas este año en senegal el estado
levanto en marzo las principales
restricciones sanitarias tras una
disminución de los casos en el país de
mayoría musulmana
pues se calcula que cerca de la mitad de
la población del continente africano
profesa el islam
por eso el mes sagrado de ramadán se
siente con fuerza en las diferentes
naciones
previamente hablamos con mohamed va xavi
al hassani creyente musulmán nacido en
ghana y radicado en colombia donde
lidera una de las principales mezquitas
de la capital del país y esto fue lo que
nos contó
muy importante muy importante el
continente africano porque nosotros nos
gustaba mucho ramadán cuando llegue a la
mar al rompemos alguno con eso con la
dura vamos es algo que rompemos alguno y
compartir
de sabiduría entre nosotros mismos
leemos cortan todo todo el día
ayuno son 30 días o 29 10
porque 29
depende de la luna
hay uno
cuando llega nosotros hacemos el
matrimonio muchachas muchachos todo lo
que ya había tener
de importancia o tener conocimiento a
ellos mismo y hablar pero nos está
obligando a nadie
a cazar a no saber dando a nadie depende
a entre mujer y hombre cuando ellas
quieren y se sienten y hacer su materno
y en áfrica siete días hablamos de la
diáspora africana en bolivia porque una
monarquía afrodescendiente sobrevive
desde hace tiempo desde tiempos de la
esclavitud en la zona subtropical de los
yungas en ese país de américa del sur el
rey julio primero defiende la herencia
africana en un país donde la
invisibilidad es su peor enemiga además
de otras problemáticas como la pandemia
y los conflictos sociales pero su
historia sigue viva para las nuevas
generaciones
pero si todos estamos ahorita en la
tumba desde y bonifacio
está así como pueden ver un poco
descuidada y gracias a los vándalos
del sector rolando pinedo es
descendiente de bonifacio y nieto del
actual rey de los afrobolivianos su
majestad julio pinedo que vive en
mururata en una zona subtropical de
bolivia su ancestro real más antiguo
según la historia es el príncipe y
chicho traído a las haciendas de esta
zona como esclavo desde senegal durante
la colonia los españoles que son traídos
para trabajar en la misma de potosí y de
ahí también un día los patrones que ya
estaban
y hay más
en los terrenos hacían así cada uno a su
patrón lo llamaba entonces ahí les
habían traído ya para trabajar a la
hacienda julio pinedo fue reconocido
como rey de los afrobolivianos en la
fiesta de la pascua de 1992 tiene 81
años y está casado hace 52 con angélica
larrea
pese a los reconocimientos son una
pareja sencilla de agricultores que
tiene una tienda de abarrotes sin que su
estatus implique un trato especial el
gestor cultural alejandro barra busca
que los jóvenes conozcan la historia
del pueblo que no sabe su historia y su
cultura es como una persona sin memoria
los afrodescendientes rondan los 35 mil
en todo el país pero su cuna estuvo en
estas tierras ancestrales de los yungas
donde comenzó la historia de la
monarquía afro boliviana cambiamos de
información porque níger está de luto
luego de que 20 menores de edad entre
los 3 y los 5 años carne atrapados en
las llamas de un incidente en una
escuela a las afueras de la ciudad de
miami la capital del país todos ellos
murieron ya que las instalaciones hechas
de madera y paja fueron rápidamente
consumidas por el fuego sin darles
tiempo de escapar
estas son las instalaciones donde
estaban los niños fallecidos en un
incendio que tiene a níger de luto al
menos 20 menores de edad quedaron
atrapados en las llamas que devoraron
una escuela en el barrio de pib en la
ciudad de niamey horas después de la
tragedia el primer ministro visitó el
lugar y dijo que habría un castigo si se
comprueba que alguien inició el incendio
deliberadamente criminal
si el incendio se trata de un crimen
entonces tengan la seguridad de que
encontraremos a los perpetradores y
haremos todo lo posible para asegurarnos
de que reciban una sentencia máxima con
sus hijos
porque no es aceptable perder niños tan
pequeños es realmente triste expreso mi
más sentido pésame a las familias todas
mis condolencias la escuela incendiada
tiene cerca de 800 estudiantes incluidos
niños en guardería fueron los más
pequeños las víctimas de esta tragedia
por último se trata principalmente de
niños en edad preescolar de 3 4 y 5 años
también hay niños más grandes pero no
son muchos y tal vez hay dos o tres de
ellos youtube
pero la mayoría de los que murieron
quemados en esta tragedia son los del
preescolar porque son los más pequeños y
no pudieron correr los equipos de
rescate trabajaron rápidamente pero no
lograron controlar la intensidad del
fuego el viento hizo que las llamas
llegaran a varios salones de clase las
autoridades aún no conocen el origen del
incendio en níger que está entre los 10
países más pobres del mundo según el
índice de desarrollo humano de la onu
este tipo de aulas al aire libre se
utilizan a menudo para dar cabida a los
estudiantes en escuelas superpobladas
hablamos ahora del coi 19 porque si bien
la vacunación en el continente africano
avanza a paso lento hay un país que
repunta entre los más avanzados a nivel
global veamos
se trata de marruecos la nación
norteafricana fue la primera en iniciar
su campaña masiva en el continente ya la
fecha vacunado al 12.5 por ciento con la
primera dosis equivalente a más de 4.5
millones de personas y al 11,5 por
ciento con las dos dosis necesarias para
obtener la inmunidad lo que equivale a
más de 4,1 millones de personas cuál ha
sido la estrategia marroquí para lograr
estos importantes resultados sobre el
tema hablamos previamente con el
epidemiólogo marroquí y heyker jafar y
esto fue lo que nos contó con el enfoque
histórico modelo mejor dicho del humor
para empezar es necesario entender que
históricamente marruecos desde el mes de
octubre a noviembre de 2020 ya tenía
unas orientaciones reales que le
pidieron al gobierno prepararse para la
vacunación cómo gestionar todas las
dosis necesarias y preparar un plan
estratégico identificar la población
objetivo que iba a ser vacunada de
primeras y cuál sería la estrategia
operacional operacional
y un segundo momento importante fue
cuando las instrucciones reales le
pidieron al gobierno que la vacunación
fuera gratuita tanto para los marroquíes
en el territorio como para los
extranjeros que viven en marruecos
entonces marruecos ha instalado más de
3000 puntos de vacunación a través de su
territorio con una logística bajo la
supervisión del ministerio del interior
y logística supervisión de ministro del
área y empezó a vacunar a la población
según un plan de priorización particular
primero las personas mayores de 70 años
también nosotros
el personal médico los militares
nuble profesional de satélite y yo yo le
pago lo mejor los que lo jacta y ahora
yo no tengo duda de que cuando marruecos
tenga entre el 60 y el 80 por ciento de
la población objetivo vacunada que
esperamos lograrlo el próximo mes va a
intentar crear una plataforma de
fabricación de vacunas en territorio
marroquí que servirá no sólo a marruecos
sino a los demás países africanos y a
otros países y días de desarrollo el
segundo 2 opinión web de plomo
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con música de tigua savaglio
una de las grandes voces del afrobeat
nigeriano y de sus videoclips más
virales titulado córdoba
en este videoclip que transcurre entre
un tradicional salón de belleza afro y
un barrio popular nigeriano la artista
muestra algunas de las costumbres
contemporáneas del país y resalta en
ellas el papel de la mujer con esta
buena música finalizamos este capítulo
de áfrica siete días pero ustedes pueden
continuar con más en nuestra página web
www punto frente y 4 punto com nos vemos
más adelante con más información que
deben ser estos trans bendigo
[Música]
son malos
y
colo colo que los colocas con los
báculos y canarias sólo para colocar
colocas con los vaqueros y acarrea todo
lo que lo coloca con un pacto para
dedicarme a esto aquí tengo aquí vamos